okay today I'm going to talk to you
about displacement reactions a
displacement reaction is when a more
reactive element takes the place of a
less reactive element we're gonna have a
look at example right here so let's
imagine that this is a solution in a
test tube or a boiling tube of copper
sulfate and what we have here is we have
an iron nail so I've put in the the I
male into copper sulfate to see if
there's going to be some kind of
reaction so let's just write out this
word equation to begin with so I've got
copper sulfate and I'm added that to
iron now in order to see if a reaction
is going to take place I need to have a
look at the reactivity series so if you
remember the reactivity series just has
the most reactive elements near the top
and the least reactive elements near the
bottom so the two things I'm going to be
looking at is comparing copper to iron
so there is iron and there is copper so
because iron is closer to the top it is
more reactive than copper so what is
going to happen is that iron is going to
displace the copper means it takes its
place so like this now what we're left
with is going to be this because the
iron has displaced got rid of the copper
kicked it out we now have iron sulfate
so that is one that's the name of the
sorts that is produced iron sulfate but
we still a copper is now all by itself
so it's iron sulfate plus copper this is
a displacement reaction the more
reactive element has replaced a less
reactive one just going to quickly do
the word equation underneath just so we
have it in both forms and plus Fe goes
to iron sulfate
plus copper okay
now let's have a look at a different
example let's imagine now we had zinc
sulfate instead of copper sulfate and
this time let's imagine we reacting it
with copper so let's have a little look
at the reactivity series to see if
there's going to be a reaction so
remember the most reactive metal so just
move that cross the most reactive metals
are near at the top so if we're
comparing zinc with copper we can see
that zinc is more reactive of copper
because it's further that way
as a result copper cannot displace the
zinc it's not reactive enough it's less
reactive than zinc so if I added copper
to zinc sulfate there would be
absolutely no reaction it's not reactive
enough similarly if I had copper sulfate
let's imagine I've got copper sulfate
like in the first example but I added
copper to it because they have the same
reactivity obviously it's the same
element because it's the same reactivity
again you would also see no reaction as
well so in order for a displacement
reaction to take place we must have a
more reactive element most of of more
reactive elements such as iron reacting
with a less reactive element like copper
so these two would be a good example and
that is just how displacement reactions
work they're an example of a redox
reaction and if you'd like to learn more
about redox reactions please watch the
video about redox reactions thank you
very much